يلتقي قاده دول الجناح الشرقيه للنيتو و
يؤكد تكبيد القوات الروسيه خسائر فادحه في
جبهات الشرق
فرنسا تراقب انشطه شركات صينيه تدعم روسيا
وترجيحات بزياره الى كياب الشهر المقبل
بعد المانيا النمسا تحتج على حكم طهران
بسجن احد مواطنيها وتستدعي سفير ايران في
فيينا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى فتره اخباريه جديده
من العربيه نبداها بهذه النشره يجري
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن اليوم وحدثات في
وارسو مع اعضاء مجموعه بوخارست ناين والتي
تضم دول الجناح الشرقيه لحلف النيتو ومن
المقرر ان يجدد رئيس بايدن خلال اللقاءاته
تاكيده على دعم اوكرانيا في مواجهه روسيا
وعلى دعم بلاده الثابت للجناح الشرقي في
حلف شمال الاطلسي مجموعه بوخارست 9 تضم
اعضاء في حلف الناتو من شرق ووسط اوروبا
وهي بلغاريا وهنغاريا وستونيا
وبولندا ورومانيا وسلوفاكيا وجمهوريه
ووسط الاتهامات المتبادله بين واشنطن
وموسكو واكد رئيس الامريكي جو بايدن وخلال
وجوده في بولندا ان الولايات المتحده
والدول الاوروبيه لا تسعى لمهاجمه روسيا
مضيفا ان الحرب في اوكرانيا غير ضروريه
واختارها الرئيس
اتحدث مره اخرى مع الشعب الروسي الولايات
المتحده والدول الاوروبيه لا تسعى لمهاجمه
روسيا وبالنسبه لملايين المواطنين الروس
الذين يرغبون العيش بسلام فان هذه الحرب
غير ضروريه بل هي تراجيديه اختارها الرئيس
بوتين فهي حرب من صنعه المساله بسيطه على
بوتين ان يتوقف عن غزو اوكرانيا وبذلك
نصدر ستار الحرب
هذا ويعقد حلف شمال الاطلسي والاتحاد
الاوروبي واوكرانيا اجتماعات متواصلات
تهدف الى تنسيق عروض الدول الاعضاء من
اسلحه وذخيره وفق الاحتياجات التي قدمتها
كييف المصادر الرسميه في الكتلتين
الاطلسيه والاوروبيه لا تخفي صعوبات التي
تواجهها قواتها في تامين الذخيره اللازمه
التي تحتاجها اوكرانيا
في الاجتماع الثلاثي الاول بين حلف الناتو
والاتحاد الاوروبي واوكرانيا اكدت الاطراف
الثلاثه على اهميه اسرعي وتيره تزويد
اوكرانيا بالاسلحه الثقيله والذخيره لصد
الهجوم الروسي المرتقبي
بعد عام عن اطلاقه الغزو الروسي لا نرى اي
مؤشر على ان الرئيس بوتين يعد للسلام بل
بالعكس ومثل ما اكده اليوم فانه يعد
بالمزيد من الحرب الدول الغربيه حسمت
مساله تزويد اوكرانيا بدباباته ليبارل
الالمانيه وتشالنجر البريطانيه وابرامس
الامريكيه لكنها تواجه صعوبه حقيقيه تتمثل
في نقص الذخيره امام خصم يطلق 50,000
قذيفه في اليوم حسب المصادر الاوروبيه
اتفقنا على العمل بصفه مكثفه للاجابه على
ثلاثه اسئله كيف يمكننا تسويق المنتجات
العسكريه بصفه فعاله كيف ننتج وننظم بيع
والذخيره وكيف يمكننا نقلها الى ارض
المعركه مصدر وزاري ذكر ان كيف طلبت
تزويدها بمليون قذيفه كلفتها تبلغ اربعه
مليارات يورو دول الاتحاد الاوروبي تتشاور
فيما بينها حول امكانيه تمويل الاتحاد
عمليه انتاج الاسلحه والذخيره الحربيه على
الصعيد الاوروبي عمليه معقده وغير مسبوقه
نبحث امكانيه اصراع وتيره نقل الاسلحه
والذخيره من دول الاتحاد الى اوكرانيا
وتتوالى اليه صندوق السلام الاوروبي دعم
اوكرانيا منذ بدايه الحرب وقد بلغت
مساعدات الاتحاد والدول الاعضاء العسكريه
لاوكرانيا 12 مليار يورو في العام الاول
من حرب اوكرانيا زودت دول الناتو قوات
اوكرانيا بكميات هائله من الذخيره جزء
منها سحب من الاحتياطيات الاستراتيجيه لكل
منها
وتتوجب الان اعاده تشكيلها امام الدول
الغربيه اسابيع قليله لنقل الدبابات
الثقيله الى ارض المعركه وتوفير الذخيره
اللازمه عمليه معقده قد يصعب تنفيذها في
وقت وجيز يعد فيه الطرف المقابل اي روسيا
هجوما واسعا نطاق حسب تقدير المصادر
الرسميه هنا
نور الدين الفريد العربيه بروكسل
رئيسه الوزراء الايطاليه جورجيا ميلوني
قالت ان بلادها تدرس تزويد بمزيد من انظمه
الدفاع الجوي واكدت بلونه ان منح اوكرانيا
طائرات مقاتله غير مطروح للنقاش بعد وان
اتخاذ مثل هذه القرارات يتم بالتشاور مع
الشركاء الدوليين كنت
عندما تتعرض دوله ما للاعتداء فان جميع
الاسلحه التي تتلقاها تكون عباره عن اسلحه
دفاعيه والان لم يعد توليد الطائرات
لاوكرانيا مطروحا على الطاوله وان اتخاذ
مثل هذه القرارات يتم من خلال التحدث الى
الشركاء الدوليين نحن نركز في هذه المرحله
بشكل اساسي على مساله انظمه الدفاع
المضاده للطائرات
ميلوني اضافت خلال لقاء صحفي مشترك مع
زينيسكي ان بلادها تجهز لمؤتمر اعاده
اعمار اوكرانيا في ابريل وان ايطاليا
ستقدم لكييف كل انواع الدعم الذي تحتاجه
على تنظيم مؤتمر حول اعاده اعمار اوكرانيا
في ابريل ونعتزم التعاون فيه بشكل كبير
هناك خبره فنيه يمكن ان تقدمها الشركات
الايطاليه وسنوفر كل شيء لان ايطاليا تريد
ان تلعب دورا رائدا في اعاده اعماري هذا
البلد بدءا من اليوم
اشد رئيس الاوكرانيه
بصمود قوات بلاده على خط المواجهه فيما
تتحدث روسيا عن احراز تقدم نحو هدفها
الرئيسي بالمنطقه وقالت المسكي في خطابه
الليلي انه لم يطرا اي تغيير على الخطوط
الاماميه رغم الضغط الكبير من جانب القوات
الروسيه
هي تلك الوارده من دونيسك
قواتنا تتشبث بمواقعها على خط المواجهه في
شرق اوكرانيا ضد الهجمات الروسيه المستمره
والتي لم تتوقف على الرغم من تكبدها خسائر
فادحه من المهم جدا ان نذكر انه لم يطرا
اي تغيير على الخطوط الاماميه على الرغم
من الضغوط الكبيره التي تواجهها القوات
الاوكرانيه واشكر جميع مقاتلين الصامدين
في الجبهات الاماميه
في المقابل اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان
جميع المعلومات التي تتحدث عن امتناع
الوزاره عن امداد القوات المتطوعه فيسك
بالذخيره غير صحيحه على الاطلاق واضاف
البيان انه في غضون يومين فقط تلقت
الوحدات القتاليه المتطوعه
260 قذيفه صاروخيه لقاذفات الصواريخ
المتعدده واكثر من عشره الاف قذيفه
للمدافع ذات العيار الكبير وما دفع الهون
كما استلمت
980 ذخيره مخصصه للدبابات واكدت الدفاع
الروسيه ان جميع طلبات الذخيره التي
تحتاجها الوحدات المتطوعه خلال الشهر
الجاري سيتم تقديمها خلال الايام المقبله
اعربت اوكرانيا على لسان سفيرها في باريس
عن املها في ان يزورها الرئيس الفرنسي
ايمانويل ماكرون في مارس المقبل لكن مصادر
دبلوماسيه فرنسيه اكدت ان ماكرون لا يريد
ان يزورك خالي الوفاض بل يامل ان يذهب
اليها وفي يده مفتاح اعلانات ملموسه واشاد
السفير الاوكراني بمستوى الدعم غير
المسبوق لبلاده من قبل باريس منذ بدايه
الحرب
اعلنت وزيره الخارجيه الفرنسيه كاثرين
يقولون ان بلادها تراقب انشطه شركات صينيه
يحتمل ان تقدم مساعده لروسيا في حربها في
اوكرانيا الوزيره الفرنسيه اضافت في
تصريحات لقناه فرنسيه ان هناك شركات صينيه
خاصه تراقب باريس وتراقب انشطتها عن كثب
ولد سؤالها عن مواقع هذه الشركات على
الاراضي الاوكرانيه ردت بالقول انها ليست
بالضروره على الارض
ذكريات الماضي وانعكاساتها على الحرب
الاوكرانيه دائما ما كانت حديث الرئيس
بلاديمير بوتين هذه المره سلط
او سلطه الفرنسيه الضوء على طفوله وشباب
الرئيس الاوكراني
مع الهيمنه السوفيتيه على بلده او بلدته
في اوكرانيا
موقف الرئيس الاوكراني من الاتحاد
السوفيتي ومن ثم روسيا لم يكن يوما وليدا
لحظه عداء بل تراكم منذ الصغر زيليسك
الرئيس لم يختلف يوما عن الطفل مواقف عده
رصدتها لوموند الفرنسيه عكس التاثير نشاه
زلنسكي على توجهاته وصراعه الدائري مع
روسيا مرحله الطفوله كان عمر الطالب
زيلنسكي عشره اعوام عام
1988 اثناء الاحتفال بثوره اكتوبر او
الثوره البلشفيه امر المعلم بوقوف الطلاب
في ساحه الشعله الابديه في بلدته ووفقا
الفرنسيه لا ينسى زينسكي توبيخه مع زملائه
بسبب عدم كي الوشاح الاحمر لمنظمه الشباب
الشيوعي مرحله الشباب في شبابه اعتاد
زلنسكي على الاحتفال امام النصب التذكاري
للجنود الذين حرروا مدينته عام
1944 وفي عام 2023 لم يتغير النصب
التذكاري وظل الذكرى تحرير بلدته من
النظام الشيوعي ترافق مشواره من الفن الى
السياسه رمزيه مسقط راس زلنسكي مدينه
كريفيريخ كانت مركزا مهما للمجهود الحربي
ايام التحدي الجمهوريات السوفيتيه وظلت
كذلك الى اليوم فلم يعد زيلنسكي الى مسقط
راسه منذ بدء الحرب بسبب القصف المتواصل
عليها
لكل من الرئيسين الاوكراني والروسي مخزون
من ذكريات الماضي صور ضلت عالقه في
الاذهان وتظهر على السطح كل ما اشتدت حده
الصراع الروسي الاوكرانيه عن السمان
العربيه
نشاط الصباح من العربيه مستمره معكم وفيها
بعد هذا الفاصل من تحت الانقاض الى احضان
دافئه قصه الرضيعه السوريه عفراء التي نجت
من الزلزال
نواصلوا مع حضراتكم لتقديم النشاط الصباح
من العربيه الرضيعه السوريه المعجزه عفراء
ولدت تحت حطام الزلزال الذي دمر منزلها
ونال من والدتها في السادس من فبراير
الجالي لياخذها القدر الى احضان الزوجه
عمتها التي الذي تبناها بعد موجه عالميه
عرضت طلب تبنيها المزيد في تقرير التالي
[موسيقى]
وانا عم احفر طلع صوت الطفله هي بلشت تصرخ
انا ما بالي انها الطفله او كذا فلشت اصيح
وكذا اقول لهم ابو ردينه عايش عايش بلشت
اشيل النوبه التراب طلعت هي الطفله
[موسيقى]
هزه ارضيه في هتايا التركيه اكملت تدمير
ما تضرر من مباني في الزلزال الاول قوتها
كانت 6.3 على سلم
سته الاف هزه ارضيه واكثر خلال الاسبوعين
الماضيين ضربت جنوبيه تركيا وشماليه سوريا
منذ اول زلزالين في السادس من فبراير
الحالي
كل الارتدادات التي ضربت تركيا وسوريا
والبلدان القريبه كانت عند الاربع درجات
على سلم ريختار الا ان زلزال امس فقد ست
درجات الامر الذي اثار تساؤلات حول ماهيته
هل هي هزه ارتداديه ام انه زلزال اخر
علميا حسب هيئه المسح الجيولوجي الامريكيه
تكون الهزات الارتداديه اقل قوه من
الزلزال الرئيسي وتتناقص تدريجيا الى ان
تنتهي هذا يدل ان المنطقه المنكوبه هي في
ذروه النشاط الزلزالي
الهيئه الامريكيه اكدت ان الزلزال الاول
في غاز عنتاب تسبب في كسر على الفالق
الزلزالي طوله يصل الى 350 كيلومترا
ويتطلب هذا النوع من الكسور الى وقت طويل
لكي يلتئم وبالتالي يجب توقع حدوث هزات
اخرى
الاخبار الكاذبه والتنبؤات غير العلميه
التي انتشرت عبر وسائل التواصل اثارت ضجه
وزادت مخاوف الجمهور لكن هيئه المسح
الجيولوجي الامريكيه نفت بشكل قاطع قدره
التنبؤ بالزلازل الكبيره
انس النماسي العربيه
اتجاه تصاعدي تتخذه الهزات الارتداديه
التي اعقبت زلزال سوريا وتركيا عددا وقوه
حيث وقعت اكثر من سته الاف واربعين هزه
ارتداديه وصلت قوه احداها ل 6.4 درجه اي
بمثابه زلزال اخر هذه الحقائق اضيفت الى
تحليلات تهويليه وتنبؤات بان الهزات هي
تمهيد لزلزال اكبر واقوى لكن ما هي الهزات
الارتداديه وهل فعلا هناك زلزال اخر متوقع
اكثر تدميرا وفق خبراء جيولوجيين كلما
كانت الهزه الاساسيه قويه كلما تبعتها
هزات ارتداديه اكثر على مدى اطول يمتد
احيانا لايام واسابيع وحتى اشهر فعند وقوع
زلزال قوي يتحرك قسم كبير من الفالق
الزلزالي المسبب ولكن ليس بالكامل
وبالتالي القسم الذي لم يتحرك سيواصل
اتركه بعد الزلزال لحين عوده الارض الى
طبيعتها وهو ما يسبب الهزات الارتداديه
خبراء اكدوا ان بعض الهزات لم تكن
ارتداديه بل هزات مستقله حدثت على فوالق
اخرى نتيجه ضغط تسبب به الزلزال الكبير
على ما يحيط من فوالق اما التحذير من
امكانيه وقوع زلزال اقوى فاحتماليته ضعيفه
وفق علماء بحكم عدم اتصال الفوالق لا سيما
ان الزلزال القوي الذي ضرب قبل اسبوعين
حرر القسم الاكبر من الطاقه الضاغطه فيما
القسم الاخر ينتقل من مكان الى اخر ويحدث
الاهتزازات
اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه النمساويه ان ايران
حكمت على مواطن النمساوي اعتقل في طهران
نهايه اكتوبر الماضي بالسجن سبع سنوات
ونصف بتهمه التجسس مع الغاء عامين من
العقوبه في حاله حسن السلوك وذكرت
الخارجيه النمساويه انها استدعت سفيره
ايران في فيينا احتجاجا على هذا الحكم
قالت وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه انلينا
بربوك ان حكم ايران بالاعدام على الايراني
الالماني خمشيد شرمهد غير مقبول على
الاطلاق واكدت وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه
ان تطبيق ايران حكم الاعدام على شرم مهدي
سيقابل برد قوي هذا وكانت وسائل اعلام
ايرانيه كشفت ان القضاء الايراني حكم
بالاعدام على المواطن الايراني الالماني
خمشيد شارمان بتهمه الفساد في الارض
شدد رئيس التونسي قيس سعيد على ضروره
اتخاذ اجراءات عاجله لوقف تدفق المهاجرين
غير النظاميين من افريقيا الى بلاده واكد
صعيد خلال تراسه اجتماعا لمجلس الامن
القومي ان ظاهره توافد المهاجرين غير
النظاميين تؤدي الى عنف وجرائم وممارسات
غير مقبوله يجب وضع حد لها
تونسيا ايضا قرر قاضي التحقيق بالقسم
القضائي لمكافحه الارهاب في تونس مواصله
التحقيق مع رئيس حركه النهضه راشد الغنوشي
حيث سيمثل مجددا غدا امام القضاء بتهمه
استخدام كلمه الطاغوت ولقاء عناصر من
تنظيم انصار الشريعه الارهابي
مره اخرى يمثل امام قطب القضاء لمكافحه
الارهاب راشد الغنوشي رئيس حركه النهضه
بتهمه جديده تتمثل في استعماله كلمه تاغوت
وهي العباره ذاتها التي كان يستعملها
تنظيم انصار الشريعه الارهابي المحظور في
تونس عندما كان يؤذن احد انصار النهضه
التصريح واضح لكن الغنوشي يسر على ركوب
صهوه الهروب الى الامام
عرب
ويتم بملفات فارغه لا تثمن ولا تغني من
جوع
الغنوشي متهم ايضا بلقاء عناصر من تنظيم
انصار الشريعه الارهابيه اما المخطط قد
يكشف عنه البحث عن لمثوله الخميس المقبل
امام قطب مكافحه الارهاب القضايا المرفوعه
ضد الغنوشي وغيره اعتبر التعافير للسلطه
القضائيه تعافي القضاء سيفتح بابا لكل
لبحث كل القضايا العالقه وهذا سيحتاج الى
الكثير من الوقت لان القضايا الارهابيه
ليست قضيه سرقه موصوفه يمكن ان يتم
اثباتها على سارق وبالتالي تحتاج الى وقت
الى الجهد وتشهد تونس موجه ايقافات لعدد
من المتورطين في قضايا فساد وتامر على امن
الدوله تنظر فيها الدوائر القضائيه
المختصه
المؤسسه القضائيه وتخلصها من سيطره
الاخوان تعددت التهم والمواجهه لراشد
الغنوشي بين قضاء الارهاب وتبييض الاموال
والفساد في انتظار استكمال تحقيق معه
بوصفه المسؤول الاول عن العشريه السوداء
ومهندسه ما رفقها من احداث وليد عبد الله
العربيه
تونس
عبر رئيس مجلس القياده اليمني رشاد
العليمي عن شقه للسعوديه بعد ايداعها
مليار دولار في حساب البنك المركزي اليمني
وقال ان السعوديه صاحبه رؤيه المسؤوله
تجاه اليمن ولا طالما ساندت اقصاد اليمن
وخفافه من معاناه شعبه
كما اشاد رئيس الوزراء اليمني معين عبد
الملك بالوديعه السعوديه مؤكدا انها ستدعم
جميع مؤسسات الدوله اليمنيه واضاف عبد
الملك في تصريحات للعربيه ان الوديعه
السعوديه ستسهم في تحقيق الاستقرار النقدي
وستدعم قدرات البنك المركزي اليمني للوفاء
بالتزاماته واشار ايضا الى ان اليمن
يواجهوا تحديات كبيره في ظل تهديدات
الارهابيه
وكان مصدر صعودي كشف ان ريال ستقوم بايداع
مبلغ مليار دولار في البنك المركزي اليمني
ياتي ذلك في وقت تكافح الحكومه اليمنيه
ضعف العمله وارتفاع اسعار الوقود والسلع
الاوليه ومواجهه انعدام الامن الغذائي في
البلاد ويعاني اليمن ازمه اقصاديه
وانسانيه حاده هي الاسوا في العالم حسب
الامم المتحده في ظل الحرب والفجوات
الحاده في التمويل والتضخم العالمي
والتاثير غير المباشر للحرب في اوكرانيا
افادت مصادر مطلعه بان كبار مساعد رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي بين يمين نتنياهو
يجرون محادثات سريه مع رئيس الفلسطيني
محمود عباس منذ شهرين تقريبا وذلك في
محاوله لتهدئه التوترات المتصاعده في
الضفه الغربيه حسب ما اورد موقع اكسيوس
تحركات ومحادثات فلسطينيه اسرائيليه سريه
يجريها كبار مساعدي رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتينياهو والرئيس
الفلسطيني محمود عباس في محاوله لتهدئه
التوتر المتصاعد في الضفه الغربيه
بحسب تقرير نشره موقع اكسيوس فان هذه
المحادثات السريه انطلقت منذ شهرين وتعد
من بين اولى الادله على المشاركه المباشره
رفيعه المستوى بين السلطه الفلسطينيه
والحكومه الاسرائيليه اليمينيه الجديده
التي
ركزت على الجهود المبذوله لتهدئه الوضع في
الضفه الغربيه حيث يتصاعد التوتر منذ عده
اشهر وايضا العمل على تسويه التفاهمات
التي ادت الى تعليق التصويت في مجلس الامن
الدولي ضد المستوطنات الاسرائيليه في
الضفه الغربيه والحفاظ ايضا على خط
الاتصال بين القاده من اجل حل المشاكل على
ارض الواقع وفق موقع اكسيوس الذي اشار الى
انه من غير الواضح اذا كان جميع قاده
الاحزاب في ائتلاف نتنياهو وبعضهم من اقصى
اليمين على علم بالمحادثات ومحتواها
الرئيسي ونقلا عن مستشار الامن القومي
الاسرائيلي كشف موقع اكسيوس بان
الفلسطينيين طالبوا اسرائيل بوقف التوغل
في المدن الفلسطينيه وبان اسرائيل اوضحت
انها لا تريد ارسال الجيش الى مدينتي جنين
ونابلس بالضفه الغربيه
في ختام هذه النشره نذكر بابرز العناوين
بايدن يلتقي قاده دول الجناح الشرقي
للنيتو يؤكد تكميد القوات الروسيه خسائر
فادحه في جبهات الشرق
فرنسا تراقب انشطه شركات صينيه تدعم روسيا
وترجيحات بزياره الى كياب الشهر المقبل
بعد المانيا النمسا تحتج على حكم طهران
بسجن احد مواطنيها وتستدعي سفير ايران في
فيينا
ختام هذه النشره بعد قليل نلتقي في نشره
اخباريه جديده على شاشه العربيه ابقوا
معنا
[موسيقى]